[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
throughout time our people robbed lied
and killed until one day we found
ourselves noblemen
but that nobility never came from
chivalry it came from being tough and
ruthless
the real power is not found running off
to war real power lies
and understanding of who it is you're
truly fighting
[Music]
and how they can be defeated
[Music]
I know you want to fight but there are
other ways of doing your duty come on
[Music]
we have excellent news the matchmakers
found you an auspicious match it is
decided come and sit down it is what is
best for our family
[Music]
yes I will Brianna to us all
quiet
[Music]
composed
graceful
[Music]
these are the Cortese
is it good why
[Music]
the qualities
we see Imola
[Music]
it is my duty to fight I am detective
lieutenant elliot and this is trooper
Wagner we just want to ask a few
questions
we understand none of his demise the
family have gathered to celebrate your
father's 85th birthday how was it hello
the party pre my dad's death it was
great ladies and gentlemen I would like
to request that you all stay until the
investigation is completed
what can we ask why has something
changed no no it hasn't changed or no we
can't ask one of his family walls is
that what you're suggesting
[Music]
you all love twisting the knife into one
another up your ass
oh very perfect eat [ __ ] how's that
eat [ __ ] [ __ ] definitely eat
you know something spill it
I suspect foul play
I have eliminated no suspects
to twist it web we are not finished
untangling it not yet
what is this CSI KFC my arena
Oh
[Applause]
veidt's your challenges
they're the serious versions of us
just what we need to check us up a notch
let's prove we are the best Titans in
the multiverse
so I think I know who's behind this
haha that's right we will conquer the
multiverse together and there's nothing
you can do to stop us we are in the
danger it is time for the cooperation oh
come on
oh wow yeah we're all besties now
Oh what took you so long
Santa Claus
the cost of being a hero
brooding heroes there Robin is so
handsome
[Music]
Titans go
[Music]
five years ago I thought I lost you
forever
there is no curse that could ever tell
me away from you will you marry me yes
[Music]
[Music]
vicious I have a little bit of news
don't ruin my morning
there have asked me to marry him no I
wasn't really asking nor was I love
doesn't always end well beasty
trust me let us prove you wrong you have
done an admirable job going against your
own nature to raise this child but now
she will finally get the love of a real
mother tonight I consider Elora
my peanut wedding was have you done
Aurora
Maleficent is a threat to everyone
because you are best to protect help
[Applause]
one can never be too careful
you
you do not know me
tell me what happened there was another
creature you've spent years caring for a
shoe
now it's time to careful your own Dora
for dinner if you think you know door
[Music]
she'll grow out of it
think again Dora this isn't the jungle
it's high school it's life or death
so if I don't talk to you don't take a
person oh okay I'll just try to survive
high schools a horrible nightmare are
you I'm glad you brought it I'm just
kidding I don't actually care we're onto
something big Dora an ancient city made
of gold we're gonna break some rules
we're coming with you Prima oh look Dora
brought a knife on the field trip
everybody
go
it's a jungle puzzle
the jungle is perfectly safe
[Music]
seriously you had that in your backpack
too
don't panic excuse me
I ain't chili con carne you know you can
tell when you're the world's greatest
spy long story
plan sterling
Lance Turley everyone knows the name
[Music]
don't take the law so hard I mean you
got to meet lance sterling
thank you thank you go backwards back
Chris - is too much it's probably too
right her mouth still go back to working
at home it is gonna change spying
forever
it's called biodynamic concealment
imagine if I can make you wait for it
drumroll please
disappear disappear disappear why are
you saying it like that for effect
that next generation concealment test
you wouldn't happen to have it on hand
would you
I do happen to have it in hand show it
to me sure um what can I help you a
drink
I got water drinkable meals ready mm-hmm
we had a drink
diet stuff has a weird aftertaste what's
the tech
it worked subject appears disoriented
what did you do it last look at me look
at you I can't not look at you Walter I
can see my butt and your face at the
same time pigeons are everywhere nobody
notices them girl it's the most perfect
form of I could take they're gonna
unburn me right now
that's it I'm the poison I'm Bert I'm
raising my voice I probably shouldn't be
raising my voice at you I need you to
unburden II Walter you burden yourself
[Music]
still talking to your friends it's
complicated Manny when we first got
together we were different people
[Music]
crap I hate Antony this is a Martha and
Bethany the suspense was very nice to
meet you
morning sort of burden on you you're not
barking he's barging my little Walker
yeah did you guys see Spencer think he
went back in we gotta go get him
huh
what oh you oh my god you're Spencer's
grandfather
are we in Florida thank you my little
Walker did I die it turn into some kind
of a small muscular boy scout
are we dead I'm the old fat dude my show
it feels good now my thighs okay we have
some issues here the game is busted lose
the game
I'm not yet I don't wonder yet
welcome to Jumanji
this next adventure is even more
challenging and remember the future of
Jumanji is in your hands I have one
important question who is Jumanji
is that barbers boy we did that are we
in hell and new
the thing
in the back in the Sam
what the hell is to suit your strengths
and weakness's smoldering intensity is
this stupid face you make huh he's going
on you having a heart attack
breathe breathe this whole left side is
shutting down
[Music]
good morning woman where am I
you're in paradise of course
[Music]
what is this place this is an
opportunity
[Music]
if you could learn your place you of
your best years out of you
our family sent us here to shape us in
their image
you're in our brave new world
it's about owning your story who you
truly are
what we're helped to change of your
there's always a way to get what you
want I'm getting out of here
[Music]
every night they make us sleep like
we're dead
[Music]
it says that that girl never existed
I promised I'd find you
[Music]
[Music]
David oh man I think women can do
anything just because they can doesn't
mean they should that's just the way you
outstanding angels you have a new client
who is she I can't sleep at night I'm a
lead programmer on a product that can
revolutionize the power industry but
there is a possibility it can be
weaponized ulema neat you know I'm J
who are you embossing
welcome to the pounds of agencies we
exist because traditional law
enforcement can't keep up I don't like
that boy you guys are like lady spies
thanks for mi6 Oh God
what did you do to spend my compressed
his carotid and deoxygenated his brain
stem
well that sounds painful don't worry
he's gonna wake up unless he doesn't
Sabina runs the ground game
sanyo stuff let's get the weapon before
it becomes every bad guy's favorite new
toy
take her to the closet cheer her up
we're gonna need some wigs toy
we're still in the first closet there's
another closet
just stop the touch some of these blows
up
[Music]
I love Shane are you flirting with a
handsome nerd host No
[Music]
how'd that feel cuz it looks like it
felt really good I feel nice
[Music]
good morning angels morning charlie
your husband's here to see you what
happened
how did I get here Jennifer you weren't
an accident and you hit your head
you remember me do you know you need I'm
Russell it's really nice to meet you
this is really her house it's been in
family for a while so quiet better be
nearest neighbors over a mile away only
a mile I was wondering if your wife
would come down to the station tomorrow
at 11:00 to talk about the accident what
tomorrow 11:00 I overheard Jeff said on
the phone I always work calling no
wondering when I was coming back
[Music]
I think I'm gonna head into town today
you gonna be okay
I'll be fine I feel like I just need to
take a look around maybe something will
trigger memory don't want to do it since
Jennifer had no ID how did the Russell
prove he was her husband it says here
that he showed some family photos
[Music]
Jennifer and Russell is the happy couple
right there
profess Russell who's that
what did you do to my husband
this was no accident
all I have ever one asks for you to love
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the situation in the Pacific is far
worse than reported Pearl Harbor is the
greatest intelligence failure
[Music]
in American history
the Japanese are planning something
bigger
so what's the target we believe it's
Midway
Washington disagrees
Washington is wrong
today we're gonna be underdogs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe prove the American Navy is an a
joke
[Music]
you'll remember this moment for the
besties in life
so tell me have you done this a lot met
people on the computer service don't you
fine it's always the same you mean them
special followed Bible that down but
I'll tell myself brace up this time it
will be different which astronomers law
professor a deception my god
my name is in fact not Brian it's Roy
[Music]
to the future how much challenge is
worth nearly 3 million cars there the
lot you bloody bet I'm gonna take it off
is that your grandson it's too soon to
be getting so close to him
I've grown very fond of you do you know
who you are you're the only person on
this planet who makes me feel that I'm
not alone
I know things about you who you really
are you don't wanna do this Roy
the game the adrenaline rush
[Music]
what if it is seems like you've had
quite a past enough to last several
lifetimes
I'm just a blink your last chest forever
you know it's very peculiar doing things
you'd never imagine secrets between you
God the devil
and the dead don't know him
Thomas Alva Edison my boys and I caught
in a jar but before now is only flashed
across the night sky the future is here
oh I'm George Westinghouse Nikola Tesla
I will be the greatest provider of
electrical power in the world better
than Edison there's a contest between
you this is a battle for the brightest
minds of America today the impossible
becomes possible and the man that
controls that current controls the
future I hope you brought your
checkbooks you want to be remembered
it's simple shoot a president but if you
prefer to have what I call a legacy you
leave the world a better place than you
found it you are building miracles out
of thin air I'm working on something so
new that the world would never be the
same
mr. Edison succeeds he will set his back
so far we may never recover sometimes we
have to work outside of the rules to get
was right
that is how you truly win it you got
vultures in every venture but did I
mention that his systems lethal his
current kills people he's playing dirty
you can too
you can't see the real force that moves
things on it's not ac/dc it's up towards
its currency this is costing a parts
Westinghouse star my motor that is our
future
you buy it they're never gonna be
anything named Tesla ever again our
futures not gonna be paid for bricks
fully copper I had the better system
Westinghouse Electric shall endure the
City of Light I built it already in my
imagination and it is perfectly there is
possibility you'll be putting in
jeopardy the lives of 28 million people
tonight things could change her
Oh one man would rise
so what you trade invent or fix problems
radius
[Applause]
so how would you feel about going to the
mountains for Christmas with grace she
really wants to get to know you guys
that's our mom's hat ah okay
I don't want to leave you here with the
kids if you're not feeling I'm talking
I'm feeling fine it was my idea and it's
a couple days I can do a couple days
okay guys I'm off have fun what is that
that's right I don't a minute so honey
so far
repent and you will find salvage things
are very uncomfortable opportunist and
we're stuck in a house together
[Music]
what is this the power's out where are
my things it makes no sense what I heard
something
[Music]
hello did you do that we didn't do
anything
[Applause]
we're leaving what are you talking about
look outside we're stuck here
[Music]
okay
trust me
you have nothing to be scared about
I couldn't sleep that night I remember
thinking I'm all alone then I realized I
had nothing to hide there you are
I just decided I wasn't gonna be afraid
[Music]
when they assigned her to me it was my
idea to send her to her and get her into
the nuclear division her cover an
English and French teacher I probably
not gonna sleep tonight you're gonna do
great you're the best person for this
assignment did you know she was cracking
she had no idea
no burrito what do you do haven't you
learned not to ask questions like that
the people here all have many secrets
you gonna tell me what's going on
she disappeared disappeared she could be
anywhere now we couldn't control her she
wanted to make that point there's much
more going on I'll handle it I don't
think you should get into this need to
find a way to bring him here what is
going on you wouldn't understand
and follow your protocols assuming you
know everything but you don't this is
war and in war people die
[Music]
are you pulling me out
let me ask you a question
you think he black you think them your
people for the lot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the streets are war zone
you're blue now
I gotta me to see I stay in the car
[Music]
this you already got rid of everyone
that could talk the hell are you doing
here just relax they're all cups here
this isn't what it looks
to do shut a body to mine but we got a
ghost
she's gone
I think silent even bringing about that
let's get you out of here we got her
don't be stupid
all he wants is the body camp
we have been shot what you can't be in
here with this the police they all help
it was the cops that shot me she cannot
get back to the precinct to upload the
footage on that camera every cop in
criminal in this city is coming to find
her
[Music]
you got a price on your head what you
gonna do I'm gonna expose
he races
all that is before nothing
this Mitchell playing we're still alive
on me
we've got a hard choice to make right
now are you one of us
she picked herself
murder is murder don't matter who you
are if you're evil
[Music]
we're gonna need a bigger slingshot Fred
we've discovered a third island we need
to put aside our differences and work
together to save our world from being
destroyed what we really need is a hero
actually that positions been filled
she's super smart wait who's that
and why is she all over these
achievement award I just don't think
this is gonna work okay so what I'm
usually angry talks to herself
left-handed probably a whip fun being
alone I like her
next one's a muscle
well there okay guys step 1
travel undetected to the island all the
gadgets you'll see here have been
designed with your current mission in
mind first Bing and visit spray how long
does the invisibility last for forever
why Tina we're not gonna be able to see
each other okay what's the plan
working with what we
oh it's on Shawn's back but there's a
new arrival in town
Lola who's a little alien she's about to
discover wha but our world is pretty
sweet
[Music]
but she's far from home
and in big trouble to help her get back
building to outsmart the bad guys be
prepared
stay focused and stick to the plan
let the creators of chicken run take you
on an adventure
that's out of this world get ready for a
close encounter of the Third Kind
Farmageddon a Shaun the Sheep movie we
interrupt this broadcast for an
emergency alert the Department of
Defense is confirming reports of an
unknown object entering Earth's
atmosphere an alien artifact landed on
earth we need to know why and they want
me to lead the mission the trip is six
months if all goes as planned I am
coming back I promise you
it's the most important mission in the
history of humankind it's time here we
go
we are on our way to a planet full of
aliens I found something
many of these things do you think are
out there
our first contact an alien civilization
is a risky people will die
we are all here for the same reason to
protect the lives of the people back on
earth wait what was that
I'm gonna get out
what happened here is going to happen
earth Oh God I saved the crew
st. earth
what if I can eat the seed launch into
an interstellar war who has seen an
advertisement that has convinced you
that your microphone is listening to
your conversations all of your
interactions your credit card swipes web
searches locations likes they're all
collected in real time into a trillion
dollar a year industry the real game
changer was Cambridge only to go they'd
work the Trump campaign and for the
Brick City campaign they started using
information warfare Cambridge analytic
claimed to have 5,000 data points on
every American voter
I started tracking down all these
Cambridge analytical ex-employees
someone else that you should be calling
the committee is Brittany Kaiser
Brittany Kaiser once a key player inside
Cambridge analytic casting herself as a
whistleblower the reason why Google and
Facebook are the most powerful companies
in the world is because last year data
surpassed Boyle it value data is the
most valuable asset on earth we targeted
those whose minds were thought we can
change until they saw the world the way
we wanted them to
I do know that they're targeting tool
was considered a weapon there is a
possibility that the American public had
been experimented on this is becoming a
criminal matter when people see the
extent of the surveillance I think
they're going to be shocked and I still
here for your life
yeah the powerful people that are
involved but I can't keep quiet because
if I make powerful people know the death
rights should be considered just
fundamental rights this is about the
integrity of our democracy these
platforms which were created to connect
us have now been weaponized it's
impossible to know what is what
because nothing is what it seems
[Music]
[Music]